and have you done any movies in space
man i could really see you in space
yeah i would love to i would love that
let me know how cool
how cool would it be to be like the
first film shot in space
that would be the baddest i would love
that
yeah i think it would be i mean i i
don't know space we keep going to see
shitholes man mars the moon like he's
playing like
look i'm no [ __ ] i'm no real estate
agent
well i don't know why the moon they
don't already have like a
disney world up there i know nobody
would like it to be upsetting
for some people but i think it'd be
amazing oh i think something small you
could stop in at least a rest area
you know but yeah it seems like we keep
going to these shitholes bro
mars let's be honest bro this place is a
[ __ ]
i'm not a real estate agent but every
picture you see is like this place is
garbage dude fire everywhere there's no
place you can even [ __ ]
you can't even you couldn't even have an
outdoors it's just
i don't know palm springs yeah yeah it's
like
they can build it up it's like palm
springs dirty grandfather
yeah you know it's just like why don't
we let's find a decent planet
or quit [ __ ] around man you know
spend the money send a shuttle in the
[ __ ]
zaire and let's [ __ ] habitate over
there you know
like i just feel like if if we need to
work more locally look at this
coming come on dude oh yeah and you got
dumb chicks and dudes and cheweds out
there
sitting around saying oh man i think
we'll ever live on mars like idiots at a
[ __ ] bar
somewhere you know you got one third of
the bw
buffalo wild wings population sitting
there four beers deep
man wonder if we'll ever live on mars
you know
play's a [ __ ] man sorry i i just i
didn't know
mars yeah i didn't know anybody was
gonna be here when i felt like this
but it's just kind of just making me mad
man
you know a friend of mine a black friend
of mine said that black people and
aliens don't get along well
or there's beef there's so much space
there's a new there's or there's like
beef in that community
and so i'm like yeah that's amazing
so i'm like wondering how do we get
let's get that film
you know i'll be like some guy just like
you know some guy that works for the
united nations or whatever
but i'm just thinking how do we get to
see that
you know because i'm ready to see that
that's good you know i get a treatment
outline then a script yeah brothers
versus aliens dude i'm ready to freaking
there's no way i went and watched that
good evening good afternoon
and other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw
i mean it was okay but the next video
you could watch
could be way better what if you watch a
video right now that changes your life
well you could watch this one or
watch this one watch this one watch this
one watch this one